hello and welcome to 0 plane north
hampshire okay yea though Bishop c5
lines are very solid for black quite
interesting in fact okay he played with
Knight to c6 hmm ok ok I'm going to play
with d for him and he goes back oh wow
ok with night a 4 i'm able to just pick
up this bishop hmm i think he wants to
go Queen t7 hand Bishop age three maybe
I should do this too so that this trade
is not so easily happening
yeah I like my position I think I'm why
should be a little bit better here I've
got more central control and maybe I'm
just picking up the bishop him my day
for one just take it hmm ok one idea
that he has is to take a plane I to you
for something that I could answer with
95 so maybe I just just go a 3d form and
try to arrest this Bishop tried to trap
it let's see fire again he puts an end
to this idea but it's not necessarily
that greed 95 comes into it comes into
consideration here sorry what is this
feeling me a little bit
I day for Bishop e7 looks kind of okay
yeah 95 takes pawn takes knight to e7
maybe this is something not completely
sure about it he basically has to take
now yeah I was thinking to caption
it's probably not so bad for him maybe
95 in this way didn't I wasn't so
convincing hmm I won't ever should go
afore him or not he's not really
threatening anything there
it's not easy to find out a clear plan
him he might maybe he wants to go f5
hibbett I don't really think this is
some this is dangerous one of those
famous last words sentences I don't
think that this plate is actually that
hot and then it was pretty hot um yeah I
thought these six is km let's do it
yeah I felt that this should be good for
me figures queen c7 I just play Bishop d
2 loops Iran and increase the pressure
on the C file and this f5 I mean it's
not threatening that much I can always
take he takes that form one of it takes
Knight takes b7 hangs d6 hangs I'm
pretty optimistic there and not sure
what the big thing is about him maybe
you just didn't find any decent
continuation at all maybe d5 maybe t5
now 1996 is actually not that clear yeah
d 5 is interesting
okay and I didn't see that movie huh
that's pretty good pretty good move
uh-huh
clean visually to yell what's the point
okay so he threatens / should be true
now but 96 is coming here
okay i mean i can just take probably I
should
mmm maybe Bishop e3 was actually
stronger good okay um how to do this is
defending well I was time largely a
stupid move I always got this Bishop
every idea I wanted to be ready to take
on the five
nice clean this very well
check black forfeits on time just hit I
just had to pre move e m2 not losing on
time and it was tough and think this is
this is quite interesting here coming to
me five but takes an e5 seems to be okay
for him I underestimated that somewhat
of course I cannot take now because
should be h 5 is a big issue and this is
also not helping as I cannot take this
song it's the self trap so d phi this is
ok ready for him ok I for I wanted to
fight for squares he took it and play
this is a strong move and this is
interesting this this and you loud 97
mean yeah I think I should be ok I mean
at least ok but I'm playing on some
stupid moves now before it's pretty
awful I think I should probably do this
I should have compensation for the poem
because his pawns are all somewhat weak
and my bishops are quite strong oops
something like this should be
compensation with the computer grease
stop which gives me a slight edge so
roughly compensation and this is some
inaba should be three this is just not a
good idea Bishop g2 is simple and strong
and now I'm struggling a lot in fact he
could have played poop g6 immediately
cam this is pretty much losing yeah I'm
hanging on it's again it's roughly equal
i played this now and if you would have
taken him chechik take him slide it
better for why don't care and turkey
should be six but I'm I'm okay yeah
probably Check Engine Watson to justice
okay why not why not it is pretty strong
yeah yeah um check but I only had like
10 seconds but she also recognized
pretty late that there was this time
situation
yeah why didn't see with the a porn but
it was all pre pre move craziness now
yeah it was a pre move I mean I could
have taken the bishop and yeah pretty
pretty scrappy game scrappy agreement
currently after somehow five months at
all of the slump place on play more
games and kind of gets back into the
hang of it it's not like I completely
unlearned to play Blitzen in a couple of
weeks okay well thanks for watching